direkt an der a 4 bei rüdersdorf in
thüringen hat der bund diese beiden
neuen rastplätze gebaut mit reichlich
platz für autos und sehr viel wiese für
normale lkw gibt es aber gerade mal zehn
stellplätze viel zu wenig deshalb sieht
es hier ab dem frühen abend so aus um
ihre ruhezeiten einzuhalten bleibt den
fahrern gar nichts anderes übrig als
ordnungswidrigkeit und quer zu parken
abends ab 17 18 uhr fährt man hat seine
lenkzeit werden dann wird so was gebaut
ja ich verstehe es nicht
das ist bekloppt wenige wiese und mehr
parkplätze für die lkw gesetzlich wird
vorgeschriebene ruhezeiten einzuhalten
dann macht man neubau plant etwas was
total schwachsinnig ist nach fast 20
jahren planung und bauzeit werden die
beiden rastanlagen himmelsberg im mai
2009 10 eröffnet geholfen hat den
trucker nicht jeden abend herrscht
totales chaos
neben den schlappen zehn lkw
stellplätzen gibt's quadratmeterweise
grüne brache hier würden zusätzlich noch
mindestens 20 lastern hinpassen selbst
in der parkbucht für schwertransporte
dürfen normale lkw nicht stehen auch
nicht auf den beiden bus stellplätzen
nach dieser absurden planung wurden die
rastanlagen auf beiden seiten der
autobahn gebaut
die leute die das geplant haben sollten
sich auch mal vier wochen auf dem lkw
setzen mal fahren und die situation
überall mal miterleben da spielt mit
jana ganz einfach das so ja also pkw der
absolute luxus pavée gar nix die beiden
rastanlagen haben insgesamt satte 6,6
millionen euro gekostet aber warum baut
der bund völlig an den bedürfnissen der
lkw fahrer vorbei
das bundesverkehrsministerium erklärt
die wenigen parkplätze so bei
planungsbeginn im jahr 2000 wurde für
den abschnitt kein zusätzlicher bedarf
im jahr 2015 ermittelt
dieses bestätigte sich in den
überprüfungen der nets konzepte in den
jahren 2008 und 2013 ewig geplant und
dann von der wirklichkeit überrollt
man hätte das zeitgemäßer planen müssen
einfach in anbetracht dessen auch der
lkw verkehr wird immer dichter auf
unseren straßen und das sollte bei
öffentlichen sache auf jeden fall auch
wichtig sein
das ist eine super woche denkt das war
also noch so sinn macht ob aus der
brache jemals die dringend benötigten
lkw stellplätze werden kann uns niemand
sagen deshalb werden sich auch in
zukunft verzweifelte trucker an den
fahrbahnrand stellen oder woanders ihr
parkplatz glück suchen müssen